denver when you saw the footage last
night
from clapham common what wasn't through
your mind well i'm afraid i thought it
made a
bad situation worse and i i didn't
understand it and it will be good when
there is a report to the home secretary
i'm glad she's
called for it my reading last night
showed that something similar
the same sequence happened in the west
midlands i don't know if jess phillips
mentioned this but there was
that same cancellation because the court
wouldn't intervene
and the police said it can't happen
but as in london people went there were
there for an hour they had a quiet vigil
they went away again and the police were
nowhere to be seen and you know truly
the organizers tried to cancel the club
and common one
they failed completely because obviously
emotions are
pouring over the top now
and and when it happens you know with
what looked like you were there i
i wasn't but it looked like thousands of
people you know there is no real
prospect of intervening in it
successfully this quasi-military thing
of circling around the bandstand where
everybody's just
paid good money out of their wages to
put a bunch of flowers down and express
their view
have you knew some large clawed feet on
it to
to push people away it seems to me to be
a dreadful
piece of misjudgment are they really
improving their
chances of kovid not spreading by
putting their knees in the middle of the
back of young women
and putting their hands in handcuffs
it didn't seem to me to be the right
thing to do
the reclaim the streets marches of
course and this obviously wasn't an
official one
um date back to the 1970s
when you look back at those dates i
think we've even got a
some footage of a picture of of one of
those back
back then in those days do you think
anything has really changed are women
more or less likely to be victims of
domestic violence now more or less
likely to be victims of rape and murder
i i i think things have got have got
worse
you were right to go back to the 1970s
to make the point of this
see this whole series of issues victim
blaming reclaim the night was about the
yorkshire ripper
when the police in yorkshire who
couldn't catch him for many years
told women to stay off the street
women's response to that was he's a man
take men off the street if you want to
keep people safe do not
blame us and and here we are
again it seems local police were telling
people women not to go
around clapping common uh because of the
dangers there when the
reverse is the case it isn't about
women's safety it's about
men's violence we had calls this week
for uh sorry to cut across we had calls
this week for
for a male curfew uh that was met by you
know a certain amount of hilarity from
some quarters
but when you know in all seriousness is
that something that
should be considered i i think that
there's been an arrest in connection
with this
and curfew is not the point about
um the kind of events of
uh predatory male behavior you know
abusing women on the street
grabbing hold of them flashing them a
curfew isn't going to stop that
what needs to happen is a huge culture
change
and i have to say you know if women's
voices
could change this behavior it would have
stopped a very long time ago
we need real leadership and we need
men to speak out against men of this
nature
who if they don't get discouraged take
another liberty after another liberty
shouted a woman this time
nobody stops you so um go
go to her and tell her why she's why why
are you not taking any notes of me i've
just shouted at you
stand in her way the the barriers
are pushed if it's not stop isn't the
real reflection of all the women who've
spoken out and they were you know from
trade unionists to students to
journalists people in your kind of
position jane or saying they've been
harassed in this way
that so far as women are concerned men's
the streets are lawless men can do and
say
what they wish to women on the street
with no sense of a deterrent
through fear of the criminal justice
system and no sense for these women
that they will be protected in the
criminal justice system if they make a
complaint
and look i don't want to go close to
into sarah everard's case at all which
is tragic and one's heart goes
absolutely out
to her family but you know such notice
did the police take according to the
press
of an allegation that this man had
flashed
to no doubt worried women in a
fast food takeaway a few days before
they were so
ready to investigate who that was that
they were given
a cctv picture with the
license plate of the culprit on it
i should say we need to be so careful
because there is an active court case
and we we wouldn't want to certainly
jeopardize that court case and that may
well
be part of the evidence in that case but
um
you talked about the fact that that
action needs to be taken
is the home secretary up to the job do
you think
oh it's not for me to tell the prime
minister who to appoint to his
cabinet the real point is that there
there is no doubt that
the government has been quite responsive
over the domestic abuse bill
but it simply doesn't go far enough and
the end-to-end rate preview frankly few
people have any
real expectations of it throughout the
time that it's been running i mean the
cps just stopped
prosecuting rape in significant numbers
five years ago and despite women
complaining despite a court case
despite the end-to-end rape review they
have done nothing to reverse that it
still
is 1.4 as you have already
said to yourself so there needs to be
some significant
government leadership and there needs to
be a significant
drive to change the culture to
acknowledge that we are in real danger
of losing confidence in the criminal
justice system
from half of the population of this
country you say it needs leadership it
it
it does therefore suggest that you don't
especially have confidence in the
leadership that's currently being
offered
it's about how active that leadership is
isn't it and how much it
sees what is happening and how much it
drives
that agenda i suspect that that people
have
been in leadership have been taken by
surprise
by the outpouring indeed the uproar
that there's been from every kind of
woman in the last
few days the question is now is this a
turning point well
they can make it a turning point that's
the question
is there the political will to tackle
the very serious trouble that the
criminal justice system is currently
in not prosecuting cases
against women so that it really doesn't
seem to women to be worth them
complaining let's just be really clear
increasing sentences for sexual offences
but very very few people are prosecuted
for sexual offenses so that's
not going to make the slightest
difference the new legislation
has some possibilities in it but it also
contains
a clause which licenses the police to
take
mobile phones off women with very
little control over that and off every
kind
of complainant this is a retrograde step
now the trouble that there has been
about
the cps finding their own demands for
digital download have been
intrusive and irrational and a piece of
legislation coming forward
will legitimize that kind of behavior so
we are in a very mixed picture
where nobody seems to grab this issue
and in a thorough going way go step by
step
through it and say this is the problem
let's
make an answer and can i say they do not
listen to victims
i struggle all the time i have no
statutory power it is my
voice it is the alliances that i can
make
that i can use to try to bring change
but the gap
between the criminal justice system over
here
and the experience of victims
particularly women
over here is amazingly large
and they need to do far far more than
just
not in the direction of consulting by
having the odd meeting with people they
need to be
open and ready to realize the experience
and to be determined to put it right you
say that
women's voices aren't being listened to
you know we've had two female prime
ministers jackie smith was the first
home secretary of female home secretary
back in 2007
but the queen is head of state um female
leadership
it seems does not necessarily affect
change in the in this arena
why do you think that is well one
suspicion is that it's
it's it's still overwhelmingly a
male-dominated culture i mean we
obviously have
enormous gender inequality still in
economies uh in in jobs uh in
representation at high levels of course
things have gone a little bit better
but overwhelmingly the culture that
dominates is male
it is male priorities that go forward
and some women struggling to try to be
heard like jess
um and you know arguably like some of
the government ministers who are women
don't don't pick up you know a
forward moving culture that is keen
to help it is blocked at every level
by the fact that men don't have these
experiences so it's not a priority
for men a really telling thing you know
when i was a member of parliament a long
time ago
we discussed domestic homicide in
parliament and it had never been top of
any male mp's
agenda as soon as it was really
explained what was going on
men started to take an interest but
that was a time of progress
you have to be constantly stepping and
stepping
and pushing and pushing to regress is
to redress institutional inequalities
and if you stop doing that so for
instance just
cut down the number of rape cases you
prosecute so that you
look as if you're getting a better
conviction rate for the ones you take
then the whole thing just settles
backwards
into the same old male dominated
prejudices
progress stops so easily we just need to
keep going and the government
does have to lead this